depuis plus de 25 ans les gestionnaires
de garderie sont essentiellement
autonomes chacun y va de ces critères
une minorité de dirigeants de services
de garde sélectionne par exemple les
enfants selon leur confessions
religieuses pour y mettre fin le
gouvernement le goût imposera des 2024 à
toutes les garderies subventionnées qui
sont les enfants qui doivent passer en
premier selon ce qu'a appris
Radio-Canada Québec propose que les
tout-petits ayant des défis particuliers
ou issus de milieux sociaux économiques
précaires et la priorité la précarité
économique serait définie selon le
revenu familial la précarité sociale par
la sous-solarité des parents leur jeune
âge la monoparentalité l'immigration et
l'identité autochtone notamment
autrement dit un enfant issu de
l'immigration avec des parents ayant un
faible revenu aurait beaucoup de points
et passerait avant un enfant issu d'un
milieu plus aisé
les gestionnaires de garderie salut les
efforts pour améliorer l'accès aux
enfants plus vulnérables mais ils
estiment que la centralisation prévue va
trop loin j'étais essentiel je pense que
notre réseau des CPE et sont tous
d'accord tous mes collègues on est
d'accord dire qu'il était temps de faire
un ménage est-ce que j'ai un collègue
qui est utilisé l'image par exemple du
basica pour tuer une mouche c'est
peut-être un petit peu trop intense les
ménages qui eux sont en train de nous
proposer
qu'on a présentement ça fonctionne pas
le président de l'association des
garderies privées du Québec sommes le
gouvernement logo de revoir son plan de
match malheureusement avec l'orientation
proposée par le gouvernement nos
familles de la classe moyenne ils
passent en dernier nous on trouve ces
inacceptable les gestionnaires mettent
en garde Québec contre l'idée d'imposer
des critères muranus comme l'âge des
enfants à prendre en premier il
s'inquiète aussi de la disparition de
certains critères comme la proximité le
fait que des parents habit le quartier à
Québec les parties d'opposition n'ont
pas tardé à réagir on peut pas tout
décider à partir de Québec et avoir
justement une compréhension des enjeux
locaux le fameux liste là des 51 000
noms le ministère devait la récupérer et
bien la gérer la claque avait fait son
travail en quatre dernières années puis
elle avait répondu à ce qu'elle nous
disait qu'elle voulait que chaque enfant
a une place on serait pas rendu là la
nouvelle ministre de la Famille se dit
confiante de faire les bons changements
c'est important d'avoir une politique
nationale d'admission pour que autant
les parents que les services de garde
connaissent bien les règles ducs je
pense que dans tous les cas ça va
améliorer le système après les
gestionnaires ces derniers mois ce sera
autour des parents de la semaine
prochaine de dire au ministère de la
Famille ce qu'il pense de cette réforme
majeure prévue dès 2024 ici Julie
Marceau Radio-Canada